donc monsieur stewart vous vivez dans le sud de la
france maintenant oui
euh la plupart du temps oui
[Applaudissements]
exactement combien de studios d'enregistrement possédez-
vous euh environ sept je pense que
sept est mon chiffre porte-bonheur
donc j'en ai un en
amérique
qui a commencé  par les
wilburys itinérants quand ils ont fait leur album j'en
ai trois ou quatre à londres dans
une grande église
et j'en ai un itinérant
qui m'accompagne partout dans les hôtels partout
et j'en ai un dans le sud de la france quels
beaux rêves  l'hymne techno vraiment
enregistré dans une cuisine sur une piste d'œufs
pas dans une cuisine c'était au-dessus d'
une usine d'encadrement c'est une usine
où ils fabriquent des cadres pour des peintures vous
savez
nous devions nous arrêter tout le temps
car ils faisaient beaucoup de bruit avec la
machine
ouais et il a été enregistré
là où nous avons fait tout l'album l'album de beaux
rêves
pour moins de cinq mille livres
en euh juste sur huit pistes parlez-moi de
votre travail avec bob dylan la dernière fois que j'étais
avec lui dans un studio d'enregistrement à rio
alors  en Amérique
et c'était nous deux et environ
20 batteurs
et nous continuons à enregistrer des choses et à
ranger les
bandes et puis un jour nous terminerons
un projet étrange je devrais imaginer
comment avez-vous réagi lorsque vous avez entendu
la chanson de notre  le choriste jones
jameson avec francoise fellaini euh
eh bien je ne l'ai pas entendu
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit numéro deux ou quelque chose comme ça en
france et puis je ne l'ai toujours pas entendu
tu sais ce que je veux dire
tu es par ta mère le véritable
héritier du duc de  Northumberland oh
ouais
je devrais vraiment posséder environ
un huitième de l'Angleterre
et ça m'a été enlevé parce que
mon arrière-arrière-grand-père était un très
mauvais garçon tu sais et il a continué à coucher
avec beaucoup de femmes
qui étaient censées être euh
juste ça  travaillant pour la famille royale,
il a mis beaucoup de gens enceintes
et c'était un homme terrible et ils lui ont donc enlevé
le trône êtes-vous souvent
dérangé par les groupies beaucoup de gens qui
vont à beaucoup de fêtes et veillent beaucoup
vous savez  ils obtiennent souvent
w  Ils pensent que ce sont des maladies terribles,
mais en réalité, c'est juste parce que tu es
resté éveillé trop longtemps et une fois,
j'ai pensé que j'avais une crise cardiaque à
Los Angeles, alors
j'ai réveillé un de mes amis Jimmy Ivey
et il est producteur de disques et
environ  huit heures du matin
j'ai dit que j'avais une crise cardiaque
et bien sûr
il a sauté du lit m'a conduit à l'
hôpital
et c'est typique comme la
scène de beverly hills vous savez je vais à l'hôpital et
la femme devant  moi
j'avais un enfant et elle a dit que c'était mon huitième
tu sais que tu ferais mieux de te dépêcher alors mon
ami jimmy il s'est évanoui
et je suis entré et je me suis allongé sur le lit
et le médecin est venu et il a regardé autour de
lui et il a dit ouais dave stewart chérie
et  j'ai dit oui
et il a dit que je suis un peu un auteur-compositeur
moi-même tu sais et je vais bien j'ai
une crise cardiaque tu sais
et il a dit ça ne fait rien et il a
commencé à me chanter sa chanson tu sais le
tropique du désir
qui était euh
à l'époque je ne pensais pas que c'était très
drôle mais après  rwards et je pense que c'est
très drôle
j'avais tout le monde je ne pensais pas que les
médecins seraient sans travail et les
auteurs-compositeurs et acteurs je savais que la serveuse
tu as commencé l'eurythmie quand tu as
divorcé pour la première fois danny bien ou elle a divorcé
mal
eh bien nous ne nous sommes jamais mariés alors nous  nous n'avons
pas divorcé, nous vivions ensemble
et
oui nous nous sommes séparés mais nous sommes restés ensemble en tant
que duo musical,
ce qui était assez difficile si vous y
réfléchissez, vous savez, je veux dire que quiconque regarde
qui est marié peut imaginer
divorcer et ensuite commencer vous connaissez un
groupe  avec votre femme est un peu difficile
après toutes ces années avez-vous souffert
d'être l'homme derrière annie linux
eh bien je ne souffrais pas vraiment
parce
que c'était une personne formidable
avec qui jouer et
j'ai toujours fait plein d'autres petits
projets tous  le temps,
mais maintenant qu'Annie a décidé d'avoir
un bébé et de prendre un peu de temps,
je pensais qu'il était temps que je fasse un album solo,
je veux dire que j'ai fait tellement d'albums
avec d'autres personnes, c'était une pression de
toujours garder  annie à l'avant de l'
eurythmie quand on avait l'habitude de faire des
sessions de dossiers si vous regardez les premières couvertures
par exemple je me tenais dos
vous savez comme ça et elle se
tenait devant
et euh vous savez je dirigeais des
vidéos et des choses  et je savais juste
qu'elle était un si bon point focal et
quelles choses ne préférez-vous pas
moins
bien elle perd son sang-froid très rapidement
et elle est euh
elle
devient parfois très confuse ce qui n'est pas sa faute
mais je trouve frustrant vous savez nous  201
est ton dernier album mais maintenant tu es seul
c'est vrai ouais eh bien je ne suis pas tout seul
exactement j'ai un groupe appelé les
cowboys spirituels qui est
ce groupe ici
et ce groupe est
plein de mes amis tu sais que c'est
un groupe très étrange  il y a deux
batteurs
martin chambers qui est des
prétendants et oola d'eurythmics
et j'ai une fille à la guitare qui est
une guitariste et chanteuse fantastique
et
nous sommes vraiment un peu comme un
groupe sauvage vraiment êtes-vous de la rythmique sur
glace ou  es-tu  hé fini
non je vois juste qu'annie ne sait pas
quand elle va avoir un bébé donc
c'est une chose difficile à prédire vous savez
donc nous attendons juste qu'elle
sache que nous ferons un autre album qu'en est-il de
la sœur de shakespeare le  groupe de votre
femme qu'est-ce qu'ils font
ouais elle enregistre euh en ce moment dans
la maison de euh george harrison à londres
et elle est euh
elle est à peu près à la moitié de l'album
et elle a un secret très intelligent dans
sa manche son prochain album sort
avec quelque chose que personne  croiront
ce qu'ils verront, je pense que si
jamais vous deviez divorcer de votre femme, siobhan, créeriez-
vous un groupe avec elle,
pas du tout
[Musique]
blue
you